[Music]
all right so before we start this last
game i just wanted to say i'm very happy
that that i undertook this project
it's lasted for
what probably like
probably close to a year at this point
since the first speed run video
of course i could do another speed run
and i could do a infinite amount of them
maybe one day i will
but i just wanted to
you know there's obviously there's a lot
more content left to produce i want to
hit a million subs one day
which is a highly ambitious goal given
that i need
that i'm only a fifth of the way there
but um
you know i think there there is just a
tremendous amount of other topics that i
need to cover
um and i wanna i want the channel to be
like a
vast
i want it to be sort of like a khan
academy of chess right it has
everything
in sufficient quantities to make people
well versed of all levels
for example
right now i i'm working on the puzzles
you know there will be openings
and i know that i sacrificed some
subscribers with the lack of
clickbait titles but that's just my
philosophy and that's never gonna change
so anyways the speedrun has been great
let's get started on hopefully our last
game if i win that is if i lose then it
continues okay we're playing in nm high
planes
david vest
oh david vest i know who that is
okay i've heard of him okay we have a
french and you guys already know what we
play against the french
we play e5
and now
we go knight oh he goes b6 okay so we've
already faced b6 once this is an
alternative to the main move c5
this is an alternative to the main move
c5 and
the idea of the move b6 is to get the
bishop out to a6
um and one thing that we can do to slow
down the move bishop a6 in fact prevent
it entirely
is to play pawn to c3
which is a move we normally play on the
advanced
how did it prevent bishop a6 because if
bishop a6 then we take it and we go
queen a4 check picking off the knight
okay so c6
now
there's nothing particularly special
that we have to do against the threat of
bishop basics all we really want to do
is just develop our pieces nicely
starting with our bishop let's go bishop
b3
a5
now let's think about where we want to
put this knight
let's think about where we want to put
this knight
do we want to put it on f3 or do we want
to put it on e2 if you've watched some
of my french games before you will know
or maybe
you can remember
that i have an affinity
to um putting the knight on e2 i like
putting that i don't need to why is that
because i like keeping the f-pawn free
to charge black's pawn chain in the
french
um this idea of going f4 f5 later in the
game i really like that plan because
this pawn on e6 could get under
tremendous pressure but first we need to
complete our development we don't want
to rush with f4 let's castle
let's do all the nice things and then
when we're ready we can go f4 and try to
go for f5
okay so queen takes d3
um a4 so he's obviously expanding on
the queen side he's not really
developing his pieces which tells me
that we need to
press the foot to the gas pedal as
quickly as we can
um now he could meet f4 with g6 in fact
he probably will but that would create
weaknesses on the king side which we
could try to exploit with our other
pieces so let's see how black reacts to
this he goes knight h6
okay
so that stops f5
our idea is to execute the f5 pawn break
if we can do that in a successful
version we get an amazing position now
in such positions of the closed center
nothing happens quickly against good
players all right you're not going to
accomplish any of your ideas
by being impatient you have to be very
methodical you have to know when to
develop
and one thing that i could propose here
yeah we could go knight g3 but then
black goes g6
how else can we expand on the king side
what is an alternate idea yeah so knight
d2 would be a great move patiently
developing the knight but i like a more
direct idea
think of it this way
how can how else can we contest the f5
square
yeah so i'm talking about the move h3
now i want to make it clear are we going
to play g4 on the next move maybe not it
depends on what black does
but i want to reserve the option of
playing g4 in case we need to quickly
control the f5 square if that makes
sense
queen ca
okay so he probably wants queen a6 he
wants to trade these queens this is all
very typical kind of french play and i
don't see any reason not to play g4
let's go
let's go g4
let's uh let's expand on the king side
it's weakening and committal yes but how
is black going to exploit that exactly
he's got a knight on h6 which is
entirely blocking
all of black's kingside play so i'm not
really worried about my king being
exposed to does that make
sense i mean
and i'm going to talk a little more
about that after the game let's develop
our knight
let's let's get our pieces out right
let's actually bring the knight maybe to
f3 maybe even to g5
and obviously after queen a6 we do not
want to trade our queen now that limits
our options to exactly two we can go
queen e3 and we can go queen f3 now
think for a second about where you would
prefer to put the queen
there are arguments to be made for both
of these moves
but given that we are trying to prepare
f5 i like the idea of putting the queen
on f3 more because when we play f5 we
will have our queen and our rook nicely
poised uh to exploit what potentially is
going to be the opening of the f file
right now what is our next move going to
be how are we actually going to prepare
f5 well a lot of you have already
mentioned this move we were going to
play it earlier but now that we played
pawn to g4 we can play this move with a
clean conscience and that is knight g3
and everything is now finally ready we
will play a five on the next move most
likely unless he goes rook g8 which i
think is likely as well
trying to prevent f5 thank you nacho for
114
and
start thinking about what we are going
to do in response to rook g8
i have an idea for an interesting
maneuver if you guys richie in fact even
if he doesn't maybe we won't rush with
that five
because
that move is not really going anywhere
and i'm not seeing too much danger on
our queen side so maybe we can make some
improving moves first we'll see
we'll see how black plays
okay go c5
so
in that case
i think f5 definitely comes with a lot
of risk attached to it
f5 comes with a lot of risk attached to
it and
i'm going to make a ridiculous looking
move
i'm going to make a ridiculous looking
move and hopefully
i will do a halfway decent job
explaining it after the game
i'm going to go knight back to b1
all right
go knight back to b1
looks ridiculous i know
but try to come up with i mean i'm not
saying it's a great move but
i think it's going to work out
i think it's going to work out
now the main idea of this move is to
unblock the bishop because when black
starts attacking the d4 pawn i do not
want this pawn to collapse the pawn on
d4 is holding our entire position
together
so what is the idea of knight b1 it
unblocks the bishop what can the bishop
do the bishop can go out to e3 in order
to protect this pawn
and the knight from b1 can redirect to
c3 which seems to be a more active
square than d2
or perhaps even to a3 but probably to c3
and then the rook could come out to c1
so the whole idea of that
was to retool my queen side pieces
primarily in order to protect the d4
pawn from collapse
but mostly yeah mostly to coordinate my
pieces he goes queen b5 this guy is good
and i think that this is a great
opportunity
to strike
do we really care about this pawn
all right i wouldn't care
too much about the pawn on v2
and i would try to take this opportunity
to develop our pieces as quickly as we
can what does that mean what does that
entail
yeah just go knight c3 pretend that
nothing is happening
go knight c3 and if queen takes b2 we
can just protect the knight with a rook
and now we start threatening various
discoveries
and various sacrifices are
very seriously on the cards here because
i mean his his king side is extremely
underdeveloped and i would even say
undeveloped
rook ac1
creating the x-ray against the knight
and i'm smelling a lot of tactical
potential here we also have that old
idea of going f5
nothing has happened to it we can still
do that
but we might not need to we might have
that queen side where we can operate oh
there's 97 man
this is looking very juicy but we have
to be very methodical here
i have to be very methodical here how do
we actually
break through
who has any ideas
can we go f5
well we actually can it turns out that
we can go f5
or at least i think we can go f5
but the point of this move is not to
open the eight file or the f file the
point of this move as a hint is to
create a pathway for one of our pieces
now think about what piece could go
where
how does how does the position change
well what squares are no longer under
black's control you might see that the
h5 square is no longer under black
central
right the pawn used to be on g6
so we can go knight h5 and try to get
the knight over to that very juicy
outpost on f6
accumulating the pressure and eventually
we're going to open something up and go
for a mating attack
we also could have gone pawn to g5 and
forced the knight back to g8
yeah knife f6 is a big threat
storm clouds begin to gather around
black team bishop g5 is another move
that we could contemplate a little bit
later particularly if the black king
moves over to d8 the move bishop g5
would create a pin against the knight
yeah black's position is not great
and he goes knight g8 on his own
volition
trying to prevent knight f6
now we already know from all of the
speed run wisdom
that the most important question you
could ask yourself in such a situation
is does
does he actually prevent knight f6
and if you think about that question for
a second let's do some calculations so
knight f6 check
knight takes f6 pawn takes f6
that pawn on f6 is almost as strong as a
knight it forces the black knight out of
e7
and that king on e8 is going to be wide
open i mean there's going to be nothing
around it and a sacrifice on d5 is on
the cards in order to get the rook to
see it so you already could start
ideating tactically here
i mean basically just throwing anything
of black i think is going to result in
checkmate that's why black is thinking
here
so there are a million ways to play here
um we don't we didn't have to go knight
f6 maybe it's hasty but i want to play
very concretely here
this is also known as the sam shanklin
question yeah can what happens if i do
it anyway
[Music]
okay so knight f6 we we take it upon
attacking the knight and once the knight
moves away from e7
if you take a close look at this pawn on
d5
that could be a magnet for a night
sacrifice in order to rip open the
center
open up a file for the rook
and we're gonna have a mating attack
there most likely
hopefully that's clear hopefully the
logic is
is transparent enough
what if he just lets the knight back
well
what do you mean
okay so
he's obviously thinking about not taking
the night but he decides to take it we
take it
and the question for black now is maybe
he just
sacrifices no no he goes knight c8 oh we
have a sexy move here i mean we have
several really nice moves
um
if we want to go for the materialistic
approach we have a particularly nice
move but i don't think we're gonna make
it
i think what i want us to do i mean
obviously we have a discovery against
the night but the question how do we
how do we squeeze the most out of that
discovery
well think of it this way
can we
what can we do with this knight well we
can play knight takes d5
but it would be very nice if the move
knight takes d5 came with tempo the only
issue that i see with the move knight
takes d5
is that black does not have to take the
knight black can go knight d6 knight
takes a4 is an excellent move
but there is also a problem there after
rook takes a4 rook takes c8 king d7 we
haven't really bit into black's main
pawn mass in the center so i want the
best of both worlds i do want to take on
d5 but i don't want to do it immediately
wink wink i want to get black's queen
onto a vulnerable square so that i can
play knight takes d5 with tempo what am
i hinting at we start with rook f2 and
we're trying to get the queen back to b4
so that we can take on d5 if if he's
smart he'll go queen a3 but then we have
knight b5 with a fork and that's winning
as well
so there are simply no moves for black
wherever he brings his queen hell awaits
yeah we did have knight d1 i'm very
impressed that some of you
are uh discovering this move and there
is a specific reason why
i i think knight t1 is not the most
accurate
and i'll explain it after the game
it's it's a pretty high level reason
okay queen b4 and boom goes the dynamite
finally we actually break through
and notice that the patience pays off we
accumulated the attack
and when we finally pounce it's totally
devastating
okay queen d6
again
do not get too overly confused here so
we can start by taking the knight
and start by taking the knight
and now we just need to find
one more or two more accurate moves
which
turns out not to be that easy because
our rook is hanging and our knight is
hanging and we can't really move our
knight and defend the rook or can we
the question on your mind should be can
we move this knight away and defend the
rook or vice versa is that possible
well the move rook c2 should be winning
but then queen takes d5
will knight b6 then queen takes b6 be
careful be careful knight e7 bingo
97 fulfills
all of the tasks here because he can't
take he loses the rook
that's the problem with being
undeveloped is that none of your pieces
work the way they should now we're just
up a rook the rest is easy bishop takes
f6 or takes h7
and that's it yeah what black can resign
a pretty anticlimactic end to the attack
but nonetheless
sometimes you just gotta roll with it
you know what i'm saying
okay king e7
and now finally and this is hilarious we
played f5 all this time ago and only now
are we actually taking on f5 uh in order
to open up the file
okay black will probably go e5 then
we're gonna take it
the rest is
as they say is easy to follow without
commentary
okay many ways to win in such a position
um
generally we just identify okay just
resigns and there it is
the end of the speed run that was the
final game that was a good one let's
analyze it and then we'll call it a day
okay so
b6 is
an old system that that's existed for a
long time
and again why did i play c3 because he's
trying to go bishop a6 and trade off the
french bishop if you know anything about
the french you know that black is always
trying to get rid of that bishop
now could we go queen a4 check
immediately
and
this is just to the point that move
order is extremely important
what would happen if we went queen a4
check immediately
and is that is this also sufficient
yeah so a lot of you guys are on the
right track but no c6 then we take the
bishop
unfortunately black has the move queen
d7 here and
black hits the queen we don't have time
to take the bishop we have to respond to
the tension and after queen d7 king d7
black is out of the woods
so in such situations you often have to
do the trade first
and then you can actually win the knight
so
black goes c6 in order to cover the
diagonal that's the idea of the move
bishop d3
a5
and i guess the point of a5 is to expand
on the queen side and also so that after
bishop a6 that knight on a6 will not be
easily attacked
knight d2 yeah i don't like the way
black is playing i think this is how you
play the system but i think it's
extremely dubious okay so we castle
takes takes a4 black continues to not
develop and we bang on the gas pedal
here f4 knight h6
and now h3
so here a lot of you are suggesting
the tempting move knight g3 which seems
like a more natural way to prepare five
the issue that i had with this is that
after g6
we will have a very hard time executing
the f5 pawn right we would really love
to have a pawn on g4 so that f5 becomes
more realistic
um now if you actually if you do such a
thing it's not the end of the world you
can get the knight over at f3 white is
still better
but i think h3 is just a much more
direct way
to prepare
to prepare the king's side attack okay
so queen c8 we go g4
black goes g6 and now very patient move
knight d2 just develop your pieces
no need to rush with f5
well
arch sim cat that depends on how much
material you you could you potentially
stand to win
if you can win a queen effortlessly
then in 90 of cases that's what you
should go for if there's any uncertainty
about checkpoint could you have played
bishop e3 here
yes i'll tell you why i didn't play
bishop e3 the reason i didn't play
bishop b3 here is because of queen a6
which he played in the game
and you guys might look at this and say
well what's the problem you just moved
the queen away but i wanted my queen to
be able
to move to the king side i didn't want
to make a move like queen d1 it wouldn't
have been a big deal even if i did this
thank you holy words
um we can still do all the stuff i did
but i wanted the queen to play a more
active role in preparing f5 so that's
why i played knight d2 here and after
queen a6 i play queen f3 and it turned
out after rook a7 knight g3 c5
i
kind of regretted okay knight b1 is
actually the third the third move
according to the engine
oh it's close to becoming the first now
yeah knight d1 is a good move because at
this point i was really regretting that
my bishop wasn't on e3 like if white has
the bishop on e3 then everything is
complete
so
let's to understand how i came up with
knight b1
um
first of all like you have to realize
that going backwards with a piece in
order to let another piece out is not an
unprecedented idea
i know that knight b1 looks ugly but i
also know that i'm going to bring that
knight back out of b1 at some point and
i can afford such a thing because black
has not developed he's pushed his pawns
out so i have a bunch of extra tempi
that i can use
um
one moment
and i can even show you i'm sure i can
show you an example
of of you know
a very similar idea in a high-level game
um
just a second
you know this idea of going knight b1 is
is not as uncommon as you guys might i
think it is
one moment
i want to see if i can find an example
of it
[Music]
okay um thank you i need a drink
i need a drink that's a funny one
okay anyways it's it's hard to find oh
there it is i mean alexander alakine
watch what he does um
he literally plays this move in the
opening
so
what look at this game
alakine against tardikower
london 1932.
um
okay so basically
it's an album counter gambit
oh sorry it's a budapest knight e4 is an
old move
an alakan literally in this position
plays knight v1
with two ideas the first is to open up
the bishop the second is to reroute the
knight to d5 kind of like i did
and that knight very quickly gets to d5
and everything is hunky-dory alakine
develops the bishop black gets a
weakness and elekine won the game pretty
effortlessly
so
the don't be too surprised when a piece
has moved back like this it's you know
if you've got time
letting another piece out is uh can be
the best way to improve your position so
why didn't i go f5
because after g takes f5 g takes f5 i
was a little bit concerned about a
scenario
where my pawn on d4
would become a very big weakness and
even though the f-file becomes open
it's very hard to defend this pawn
because if you play a move like queen f2
then black can still go knight takes d4
and bishop c5 so for that reason i
decided to invest some time
and let's get the bishop out first also
black shouldn't have opened the c file
that helps us
now everything is great we go knight c3
all of the pieces are out and i've only
sacrificed one pawn for it now probably
uh queen b5 queen takes b2 hasten to the
defeat but still
um
so 97 and here comes f5 gtx f5 knight
comes around to h5 these maneuvers are
all very straightforward
knight g8
knight f6 check take stakes
knight c8 and rook f2
why didn't i go knight d1 here winning
the night because after queen takes a2
it's very easy to miss the forest for
the trees this position is not that
obvious white is winning still for sure
but we've given him this far advanced
passer we have not succeeded in bringing
the rook into the game in fact we have
blocked the rook with our knight which i
didn't want to do
so
i draw the threshold usually at a rook
if you can win a rook or a queen
and trade in the attack that's often
worth it if you can win a minor piece
but do some damage to your attack and
relinquish it that's often not worth it
i figured that i could get a lot more uh
if i go directly from mate here given
how weak black's king is so that's where
rook f2 came from
rook f2 queen b4
if queen a3 then we have a fork and we
win the knight we win everything
and now here comes knight takes d5 boom
and very important move knight e7
actually
this
this move uh defends the rook and
because of the pin everything kind of
works out quite
and that's it
okay i mean he
did right to resign because after rookie
two everything is easy
any questions
[Music]
can you explain how you evaluate giving
up upon a little bit more sure
so i can't give you a formula
for when you do such a thing but
why did my intuition indicate that it
was okay to give upon first of all if
you're not sure oftentimes you don't
need to sacrifice when in doubt just
play a move like queen f2 or rook f2
nothing bad is going to happen to your
position
but
if you
look at the big picture here what was
this b2 pawn actually doing and what
specific damage are we doing by
sacrificing well not much
the only reason i would see this
backfiring is if black managed to get
the game into an end game and had a pawn
majority and look at how undeveloped
black is we get a rook to see when we
get our pieces back out the queen is a
huge liability on v2
and we get threats of knight takes d5 so
i'm just counting up
all of the sources of compensation
everything that i get in turn for the
pawn and it becomes a no-brainer i mean
you get so much in return for it
and that pawn on b2 was not essential to
the functioning of white's position at
all it would be different if we had
sacrificed the d4 pawn that is the
center pawn which holds together white's
structure
so it's you know not all pawns play the
same
you know bear the same weight the
position
[Music]
how
you decided to move in with a knight
yeah so again
i i've made this very clear in other
moments in the speedrun if you turn the
engine on you will see probably five or
six completely viable ways to continue
the attack
all right in fact the engine's top move
is the ridiculous knight ge2
the idea of which is to play rook b1
which you could not play here because he
would have dropped the knight
and the point is that the queen is
semi-trapped if black just develops you
go rook b1
and after queen a3 you have this fork
with knight b5 or bishop c1 trapping the
queen so
that's one way you can continue the
attack
but
how did i come up with the idea well
first i saw the f6 where i knew that i
wanted to get a knight to f6 for many
many moves
and i also know that f5 is one of the
main ideas that we've been preparing for
a long time so just putting the two
together when you have a breakthrough
new squares and new pathways are often
created for your pieces and so you need
to reassess the situation and see if any
new pathways any new maneuvers are
possible
and why would you want a knight on f6
well that's self-explanatory you don't
even need to play chess to know that a
knight on f6 like this supported by a
pawn is the best attacker that you can
possibly get
what if bishop b4 in that position in
this position
well then knight b5 for example it's not
scary
and black is busted because everything
why
hangs
the dude play a4
well i think he played a4 just to expand
on the queen side he was just trying to
uh grab space
and clamp down on my queen side i i
don't like the way you play this opening
i think it's highly dubious to halt your
development like this but um but that's
that's what he did
at some point moment you expected rook
g80 yeah
so i expected rook g8 here i think you
do do for the 16 months how does it stop
f5 because after f5
g takes f5 g takes f5 black and play
knight takes f5
and um
and that's it uh you are not able to
proceed any further
so after rook g8 very possibly we would
have moved our king aside thank you bill
hayes for the 12 months
dubious means suspicious
and that's all guys that's all she wrote
and this is where we're going to
end
i want to thank everybody for all the
tremendous support throughout the speed
run
it's been a really fun ride and of
course there will be plenty of other
content to go around
i'll continue to play games with
subscribers and comment them speedrun
style but in terms of uh at least the
immediate plans
uh i will replace this with other
educational content during the stream
um i've already talked about some of my
plans but i'm gonna do some thinking so
um probably we will have another speed
run a couple of months down the line but
um
you know i want to let everybody catch
up to all the videos and stuff so
closing ceremony
well um
yeah that was the closing ceremony this
is a historical moment
and we got subs to go along with it
overcast delight gifting five
thank you overcast delight
all right i'm gonna collect any subs you
guys go my way thank you
thank you overcast delight i appreciate
it
much obliged none of this would be
possible without
everybody's engagement and uh
it would just be me talking to a wall
curious chimpanzee with a five gifted dm
girl
oh my god
yeah so again
all of the five minutes speedrun is up
on youtube if you're new to the channel
and most of the 10 minutes speedrun is
up on youtube as well
these videos are going to keep coming
out for the next couple of weeks
um
but again
there's so much other stuff to do and
content to create that
i want to start moving that direction as
well
but yeah thanks everybody
yeah 2 million subscribers maybe in 25
years when i learn how to clickbait
all right
thank you guys this was fun
[Music]